there are a number of things that could
address this problem I think the primary
one is the role of so-called primary
care as the frontline for healthcare
delivery really needs to be reinvented
there are several opportunities to
innovate around what a so-called primary
care physician does and unfortunately
since the current model rewards
physicians for actually doing things
such as procedures as opposed to
thinking about things and coordinating
things we don't really have a workforce
that is engaged in thinking innovatively
about primary care and primary care
delivery so if you are able to start
thinking about paying for efficiency
paying for so-called performance paying
for coordination of care and paying for
a person who acts as the pin point for
the patient the pain in a way for that
relationship between that primary care
provider and the patient then you would
have a way to build some efficiencies
into the system
I think patron centracare is really the
ethos of primary care we as general
internist pediatricians family doctors
are really interested in doing what's
best for the patient and I think that
can become rather difficult given the
pressures put upon us by folks who
actually pay for the care because
sometimes they might be more interested
in what is the actual cost of providing
care for a population so there are two
counterintuitive forces at hand here you
want the best care for your patient
who's sitting in front of you who might
be a diabetic but then you also want the
best care for the population of
diabetics within a practice primary care
doctors don't really have the tools to
provide both and what we end up doing is
providing patient centric care but not
in the way that we would like to do it
simply because we don't have the time to
release sit and talk with patients and
think about informed decisions we want
patients to have the information and
then be able to make shared decisions
with the primary care doctor as the
person who's sharing that decision with
the patient so that would really be what
patient centric care is about
unfortunately in today's environment we
don't typically have time to practice it
right now again we're paid for what we
do which is actually a perverse
incentive so it makes us do more and
that's one of the reasons I think you're
seeing the cost of healthcare rise eight
percent in terms of inflation per year
now that obviously can't continue and
Obama has some proposals on the table to
reduce that increase by one point five
percent per year over the next few years
I think however if you start to pay for
performance pay for quality pay for
efficiency then you eliminate these
types of incentives so if a patient has
diabetes and
can self manage their blood sugars which
a lot of patients do but now we have a
tool which enables the physician or the
care provider to actually see those
self-manage values and work off of those
to help coach the patient as to how
better manage their blood sugars and
behavior then it doesn't matter where
that management is taking place so if
that management is taking place at the
home but the outcome in terms of quality
is good or better than the visit based
model then you have incentives to
provide this type of care
so there are certain systems that are in
the United States right now that seem to
be able to provide better value based
care these systems that are commonly
mentioned or Keizer or mayo clinic or
geisinger and what they do is that they
have the ability to provide care across
the continuum so if you see someone
within the system you're likely to be
referred to somebody else within the
system and that information that you
that you is obtained from the first
person you saw is seen by that second
person so you reduce the costs of
repetition additionally those systems
tend to control their administrative
costs a lot tighter and they also tend
to follow certain things like formulary
restrictions and they have decision
support for their physicians in the
electronic medical records that they use
and they all have basically a hundred
percent electronic medical record
utilization
electronic medical records are important
because they allow for information
sharing the problem with electronic
medical records is that if there are a
hundred different vendors and therefore
a hundred different records that
information cannot be shared across
so-called systems so if you as provider
ex has a certain system in me as
provider why has a different system
those in for those systems don't share
information in the current state enter
as a result the goal of the record in
terms of making information portable and
transferable is lost their very
effective within the system so the tests
aren't repeated you can see tests that
were done previous day or the previous
month they're very good for trending
tests and trending information but the
real promise of the electronic
electronic medical record is not
obtained until you have a way to link
different records with different
information systems so if you would
think of the electronic medical record
as the car so you right now the
administration is buying cars but we
need to build roads so that the cars can
travel and all that information that is
obtained at a practice in Denver can be
seen at a practice in Boston if a
consultation is required in Boston there
the promise of the record starts to come
to fruition additionally the record can
also provide a way for the patient to
have some input of end and access to
information about their care if the
record not only becomes the EMR the
elect the electronic medical record but
becomes a window to the personal health
record I believe that they should be one
in the same that the physician should be
able to see a part of a patient's record
and that the patient should have access
to the same information in a view that
he or she can understand that would
allow the promise of the record to
really be realized because once you
start giving patients
access to their information you start
empowering patients you start empowering
self management and you start really
developing a shared strategy of care
between the patient and the care
provider
I think that the government should also
think about investing in things that
enable patients to take better care of
themselves so again the medical record
is not enough we need something that
patients can see and we need them to
have access to their information whether
it's through readily available
technology like a cell phone or a laptop
or a passkey that they can go to a
public library and get their information
yes there's a question of safety but
that has to be managed appropriately I
think those are the types of things that
that the government should be spending
their money on from a technological
perspective very simple solutions that
people could understand and embrace as
opposed to again whiz-bang things that
that people typically are not going to
use it's not the technology that makes
the difference it's the implementation
scheme and the people behind the
technology that matter
I think that we can use available
technologies to really transform how we
deliver care so for example cell phone
platforms are available for patients to
manage their diabetes to manage blood
pressure we can take examples for
example from from sub-saharan Africa
where patients with malaria instead of
coming back to the clinic after they've
had the test to see whether they have
malaria or not they receive an SMS to
say yes you have it and start this
medication or no you don't you don't
need to do anything else so there's an
available technology readily available
we have people the cell phone
penetration is extremely intense
throughout the United States why not use
that platform as a way to deliver care
and I think if we start thinking
differently about technology it's not
whiz-bang it's what we use every day and
implementing that into how we care for
folks that's where we can start to
create value and a deficiency in the
system when I finished residency I
remember trying to innovate around how I
took care of my high blood pressure
patients so I started to email back and
forth with the high blood pressure
patients to titrate their medications
and to prevent them from coming in to
have a visit with me I thought that that
would be slightly more convenient for
them and really I didn't think it was a
good use of my time to sit and talk
about blood pressure when I could be
handling it over a very simple media
such as email unfortunately the payment
system didn't acknowledge that as a
visit and my practice administrators
said you can't do that I started to
think well that doesn't really make
sense for a system if I can't practice
in a way that makes sense for the
patient and a way that makes sense for
me and keeps the patient happy and
actually provides good quality care for
the patient then what am i doing in any
culture whether you have a shaman or a
physician the basis of the care is the
relationship between the person
delivering and providing the care
and the patient we seem to think that
technology does have some potential a
lot of potential but technology and of
itself is not the answer it's it's like
how we use email to share stories
together I don't share stories with
people I don't know and usually stories
that come to me from people I don't know
or spam so if I'm going to be using
available technology to to manage
patients it has to come from a trusted
source and it should be based in some
relationship so the work that I'm doing
for example is really housed in that
relationship between the primary care
physician and the patient but using the
technology to enable that relationship
again for example I have a patient who's
depressed and I send him home on a
medication there's data to show that
patients might be more comfortable
interacting with the machine when rating
their depression as opposed to
interacting with a person that's not to
say that they prefer to receive their
treatment for depression from a machine
but they might be more honest in rating
their level with the machine so imagine
if we enabled patients with the tools to
rate their with their depression scores
at home and then send those to the
provider and then have an assessment /
video conferencing which is shown to be
effective for a lot of psychiatric
issues have that assessment and
follow-up or video conferencing so these
are ideas that I think we need to
explore more in the care delivery stream